thanks everyone for getting that all
lined up let's start to have a look I'm
pretty excited because so much of this
course as I've mentioned many times has
built up to this idea of calculus and
all you've done at the moment is
differentiation which is literally just
dipping your toes in the water getting
your hands on the brushes but not
actually painting very much with them so
that's where we're staying to break into
in this topic you might remember
actually I'm not sure if it was
mentioned explicitly but the name of
this topic is geometrical up
applications of calculus geometrical
applications of differential calculus I
should say ok so because it's
geometrical applications that is why so
many pictures are involved and that's a
bit of a change from a series of
sequences which was mostly algebra ok so
if you recall on Wednesday I think what
you were looking at was behavior of a
function and here's the clear important
idea over an interval so what we thought
about was when you differentiate you get
f dash X you get dy or DX right what
that is is the gradient function that's
what it means it tells you over a given
interval are you going up you're going
down so we introduced language for that
do you remember that well we say a
function is going up over a particular
interval we say that it is increasing
well we say it's going down we say that
it is decreasing and we say it's neither
it's not going up not going down we say
it's stationary it's not moving up not
moving down it's just where it is okay
so behavior over an interval is this
language but we in calculus know that we
can actually do more than just say rise
over run from here to here we can
somehow do rise over run at a single
location even though there's no run
that's what limits allows us to do so
while behavior over an interval is what
you were kind of focusing on Wednesday
what we want now think about is behavior
at a point
okay so that's what we're going to drill
down on in this lesson and that's what
these three circles are about okay so
you remember thinking back to this right
it really depends on your derivative and
it's sine positive negative or neither
okay when you're positive
we know that's increasing well we're
negative rates decrease you what I want
to focus on today is what happens when
it's zero okay so we said stationary
right so this is a very important phrase
and this is going to be our central
circle here if you want to label it we
want to talk about these objects called
not stationary over an interval but
stationary at a points so on originally
we call them stationary points
stationary points okay now there are
lots and lots of different kinds of
stationary points and that's why there's
so much stuff on this sum diagram we're
not going to fill in this entire diagram
today I'm only going to show you part of
it but it's going to tease out some
ideas that we're gonna meet over the
next week and a half or so okay so
stationary points what might a
stationary point look like well here's
one this curve which might be a parabola
for instance has a stationary point here
at its vertex right that there we call a
minimum because it's right at the bottom
of the curve right it's the lowest that
that curve can go so this is a minimum
likewise if we turn this guy upside down
like so again at the vertex you've got a
stationary point right at that spot
you're not going up you're not going
down you just pause and because that's
at the very top of the curve we call it
a maximum now this is not too bad if
that's all we had to worry about them I
wouldn't have such a big involved
diagram but by the time we're finished
with this thing it's gonna get pretty
busy so to help you maybe if you have
another color there I'm gonna put eggs
a pools of functions that fit all of
these different objects were going to
describe just going to put examples in
another color so for example this is
Plus this is minus x squared these are
out our simplest functions that we can
think of that have a minimum or a
maximum for their stationary point okay
now because these stationary points are
a spot where you go from up to down or
from down to up we say that the function
turns around at that point it turns
around so for that reason these guys are
not just stationary points we also call
them here's your right hand circle
turning points so those spots there can
equally be described as stationary
points because at that point they pause
for a minute then it go up or down but
they can also be called turning points
because if you look on the left and the
right you find there's up-down sorry
down up or up down change happening okay
now these are not the only kinds of
stationary points there are stationary
points that do not turn and again we can
use very very simple functions to
illustrate this for instance this guy
here what curve do you know and at what
is there's a very simple example that
looks something like that this is a
cubic isn't it and of course I've got a
cubic this going upwards so it's
increasing but I can just as easily have
a decreasing cubic right okay so these
guys I mean if I'm staying with my
example functions here I guess these are
plus or minus X cubed right now one of
these things well they are still
stationary because at those points there
that I have indicated the function is
neither going up not going down it just
sort of pauses for a minute and holds on
okay but what's actually happening we
have a new idea for this we call this a
point of e
reflection should say points because I'm
going to describe a whole bunch of
things these are points of inflection
okay now because these points of
inflection at that point they're it's
horizontal if you drew a tangent it
would be a horizontal line
these guys are further called horizontal
points of inflection there we go so
where we got these different kinds of
stationary points either you're at the
bottom you're at the top or you neither
you're somewhere in the middle but the
thing that all of these take him to the
thing that all of these have in common
is that the first derivative is zero
dy/dx equals zero for all of these
instances okay now I said we weren't
going to fill out this diagram today
it's just the beginning so there's stuff
over here right now just look at the
Venn diagram without I'm not going to
fill this in at the moment without
knowing what's in here what does the
Venn diagram tell you should be here
these are turning points that are not
stationary points does that make sense I
mean that's literally what the spot the
Venn diagram means the such objects
exist I'm going to tell you about them
in future lessons and likewise if you
have a look over here there are objects
that are points of inflection but they
don't have to be stationary as well and
so we're going to fill these in a couple
more lessons